We're trying to do and then maybe Sunil
can take us through the technical details
Yeah.
OK.
and the product requirements.
30 minutes definitely is not a good
enough time,
but we'll try and cover as much as we can.
So let me just bring up my screen to
provide an overview.
So a view of what we are trying to do.
Give me one moment please.
Just pulling up the table.
I said.
Did we want to have a round of
introductions? I jumped directly. Sorry.
That's OK. Yeah, maybe, maybe very brief.
I would love to know more about both of
you.
Yeah.
OK, I can get started first.
So I've joined Nostella recently.
Today I complete 90 days with Nostella
and I'll be working with Sameer Seraj on
developing products that integrate real
world data and market access.
Data sets and we're planning to build up
portfolio of products on this integrated
data assets.
That's the data strategy we have the
first product out of this data strategy
that we are trying to work on.
Productize it,
bring it to the market is intelligent NPI
targeting. But this is not the end of it.
Hassan and Jeremy,
we we have a whole suite of products and
this product strategy has been presented
to Chris Caneta as well.
We have socialized a little bit on this
product.
Strategy,
but Sameer is very keen on having the
OK.
early release of this product with a
limited scope by the 18th of December,
and that's the reason we're trying to
take it a little bit aggressively.
And and just about my background,
I've been in this industry for 20 plus
years working on life sciences,
healthcare,
real world data assets and doing all the
things around.
That's a little bit about me and I look
forward to working with with this group.
Passionately looking at all of us working
together.
Welcome to Russella.
Welcome.
Thank you. Thank you, Hassan. Thank you.
Sunil, do you want to go next?
And then maybe he has and Jeremy.
Sure, sure, absolutely.
So I met with Jeremy, but yeah, Hassan,
so I'm Sunil.
So I have joined Nostella little more
OK.
than Jay basically.
So I join in almost like 5 fifth month.
This is my fifth month.
And I I'm in the industry from last 15
years working with real world data,
patient level data and building the
product and solution and the analytical
solution to the pharmaceutical Fortune
500 pharmaceutical payer and provider
clients.
Right now basically building a new
solution and product in integrating our
WDN market access data along with Jaya.
So happy to collaborate with you to see
how we can take it forward.
Good. Sounds good. So Hassan, I lead,
you know,
Thank you.
the data science and AI organization at
North Sala, you know,
supporting all business units have been
doing this for a very long time, you know,
as SVP of a data science at before.
But I helped build something like 100
plus person organization.
We built like 8090 AI solutions into
production. Prior to that I was at Amazon.
Awesome.
Excellent.
I built Alexa personalization,
proactive Alexa experimentation in Alexa
and.
And.
Whole bunch of other uh platforms.
Prior to that,
OK.
you know um Thompson writers somewhat of
a similar central role.
Um like uh I was uh uh head of metadata
and uh for you know the the entire
company.
Um and and several data science type of
initiators also built a startup which was
acquired in computational advertising
space and so on.
Amazing has been.
I'm Jeremy.
We're we're thrilled to be working with
you. Yes, Jeremy.
I'm a product manager on Hassan's team.
I've been working with Hassan for quite a
while,
worked on many of those products and
models that he talked about.
Started out as a data scientist,
sent a bunch of stuff to production and
then after a few years transitioned to
this product for data science role,
which I really enjoy helping to define,
you know.
Good,
actionable work to give to the data
scientists so they can deliver the right
kind of value.
Awesome journey.
So I'll start to share my screen now.
Please let me know when it's.
It.
Up for everyone.
Yep.
See
Yeah.
There.
So just starting and I at times may
switch between putting it in presentation
mode and bringing it back to the slide.
It's fine, yeah.
So this is the product portfolio that I
spoke about, which is market access,
real world data,
new products development and I will now
go into the strategy and roadmaps.
This is the suite of the products which
we've listed.
We are currently first starting with
intelligent NPI targeting and we have a
very solid reason why we're calling it.
Intelligent NPI targeting,
which I'll come to gradually.
So these are the road maps.
As a part of the road map,
all I'd like to show is the early release
for Intelligent NPI targeting is
scheduled for 18th of December.
So we are looking at this specific date.
You see the date EA for INT and PBM 18th
December.
Not the full product, Jeremy and Hassan,
this is we have scoped it out to a
limited scope because we want to get
something out and rolling and so that we
No.
can start working with customers to get
traction on whether we are on the right
That.
track with the product or we are not,
what what's going right,
what's not going so right,
so on and so forth.
So coming to the problem statement and
the solution,
so we're calling it intelligent NPI
targeting because so just like you Hassan,
Sunil and I, we also come from Clarivate.
We build the DRG Fusion platform over
Yeah.
there.
The entire platform was was being led by
me. Sunil was in my team over there.
On that platform we had two major gaps.
One was the EHR data did not have
physician clinical notes #1 #2,
the real world data for the platform did
not integrate with market access data.
Both of these major gaps get bridged with
this particular solution and this data
strategy that we are proposing.
So what we want to do is we want to
target the right NPIs at the right time,
but what we're trying to do is we are
Sure.
trying to solve very.
Specialized specific business problems
for the industry through HCP targeting,
which can only be solved through
physician clinical notes and mapping that
to market access data.
So This is why we are calling this
intelligent NPI targeting without this.
Integration,
we wouldn't be doing INT this,
that's intelligent and peer targeting.
All the use cases that we are presenting
She.
from here on are very specialized.
They're not the traditional NCP targeting.
We do have a basic NCP targeting module,
which is the conventional NCP targeting
Oh, great.
model.
Going to the next and I'll not go to the
verbose of all of this,
the entire strategy for INTI have put it
in this pictorial representation which is
all of these data assets with market
access data, medical claims,
prescription claims and EHR we are
integrating. We plan to.
Be great and have these data talk to each
other and then come up with these six
modules.
The one that you see right on the top is
the traditional NCP targeting that I was
talking about.
All the rest are the specialized modules
that solve.
Critical.
Industry problems that can be solved only
through NPIs.
That's what we are trying to do and I'll
not take each of them because Sunil has a
She OK.
working prototype and I think when he
runs us through the prototype it'll make
a lot more sense so.
I know spoke too much.
Any questions so far, Hassan, Jeremy,
anything?
Yeah, I mean,
we'd love to understand use cases in a
bit more detail, potential business value,
um, et cetera, right. High level, I mean,
Yes.
it makes sense, uh, to to as areas to,
you know, consider, Yep.
OK, OK.
OK.
Yeah, OK,
so these if the yellow bar on the top,
this is the title of the use case.
For each of the use cases we have the
personas to whom this would be targeted,
the business problem, the solution.
These are the KPIs and the KBQS.
The value proposition in terms of what is
the value to the customers,
the potential financial impact these use
cases have had or will be having on the
industry and the customers over here that
we're talking about is specifically the
pharma.
Biopharma and pharmaceutical customers
only 90% and there could be peers who
could also be biased to this,
but essentially it's more going to be
with the sales team, the brand teams,
the commercial teams.
And the medical affairs team at times
when they are working with the brand
teams on the brand strategy.
So these are the personas and the
clinical functions within the pharma
companies that would be using the this
product and the specific use cases within
these products.
These products,
so coming the first one which is the high
Yes.
impact prescribers for a disease or for a
treatment,
everybody.
we want to know who are the top
physicians,
where are these physicians consulting
with as in the facilities,
who are the top specialties in these
prescribers?
And the geographical distribution of
these physicians?
OK.
What has been the performance or trends
of these physicians in terms of growth
for a product quarter on quarter?
How many prescriptions do they have
across with geographies?
Yeah.
That's what we're trying to cover.
And of these physicians,
how many have a favorable access?
How many do not have a favorable access
for the specific product in the disease?
That is the.
High impact prescribers.
Any doubts on Yeah.
Yeah.
So there is a yeah, yes,
I have some questions here. So, so,
so the first one is it seems like someone
is who's already writing a lot of
Oh, **** it.
prescriptions,
increasing the number there and and and
hitting these 15 to 20% increase goals
may be tougher than trying to identify
the ones.
That have similar characteristics but are
not writing these many prescriptions,
right? So maybe so,
so maybe they need more education,
incentives, you know, whatever they need.
But that may be a more realistic or or a
more reasonable target.
Yeah, I like it.
Right.
So I so that would still require building,
you know, who you know everything in here,
but the recommendations would be very
different, right,
than someone who is already doing what
you want them to do.
There may be some opportunities there,
but it'll pretty much pretty, you know,
quickly hit a ceiling there.
So our typical use of this,
which every farmer uses, Hassan,
there is no single farmer who will not
want this particular use case for any of
their competitive intelligence,
any product that is launched,
they are about to launch.
They need to find out who are the
physicians who prescribe either this
product or this or a similar competitor
product and they want to.
They want the medical representatives to
go to those specific physicians.
So that is the typical physician
targeting.
It's prelaunch. I think that's the key.
CP targeting now those physicians,
what are their specialties and what are
OK, so so OK, so so so then that.
they as in which hospitals do they
consult with? Are they associated?
Yeah.
OK, got it. So, so,
so these are so it's a for a new product,
it's for an existing therapy area where
there are you know prescribers writing
current drugs but current products but
and they have the potential to get this
Yeah.
new you know be high volume prescribes
for the new one. OK,
so that that's a valid use case.
I sort of saw it more like, you know,
for existing products. Um, so, so,
Yes.
so there the, you know, targeting, uh,
you know, would would be very different.
OK, makes sense.
Makes sense and this necessarily doesn't
have to be a new for a new product launch,
even for an existing product.
A pharma company, for example,
was expecting that this product will
reach out to 10 million patients,
for example only.
But when they look at their sales data,
they find that instead of 10 million
patients,
this product has only reached to 1,000,
000 patients,
which means they have not yet found or
they have not yet targeted the right
physicians prescribers for their product.
So this could be a use case even for an
existing product already in the market.
So this is where this this use case is
invariably used by every single small,
mid size, big size farmers.
Everybody uses this use case.
Makes sense, Hassan.
Yep.
Yeah, OK.
I'll go to the next one.
The next one is a very specialized use
case which is market. As in for a drug,
there has been a new pair win,
but the pair win has not been able.
Has not been capitalized by the pharmacy.
So they have a pair win for which now
because they have a preferred tier,
the drug has gone in.
They would have expected the number of
prescription volumes to go high,
number of patients on the drug to go high,
but from the claims data they find that.
It it it didn't read the target,
it should have.
So they will now in order to go and find
that gap,
they will need to find the physicians who
ideally should have prescribed for this
drug which has had an additional pair win.
But it didn't.
So that's another use case of market
access pull through for this,
while the number of prescriptions will
come through the RX and the MX claims,
but the validity of the formulary and the
policy restrictions will come from the
market access data.
So every use case has a mapping between
real world data and between market access
data.
Yeah, this seems pretty straightforward.
I think you know from a contract
Oh, good.
Yep.
perspective because you know you have
sort of events and you know expected
outcome of an event and can basically see
where the expected outcome is not met or
Yeah.
below certain thresholds or below average.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah,
I think the the nuance will be defining
OK.
Yeah, yeah.
and according to our business what is a
pay or win in each case because it's
Yep.
probably not going to be consistent.
So but that's the detail we.
Yeah, and all, yeah.
And also I think it will have a it will,
Yes, Jen, that's right.
yeah, it will have this aspect of.
And additionally, Jeremy,
because you're gonna be work, yeah.
No, no, go,
go ahead finish and then I'll I'll share
No, please go ahead. Yeah, yeah,
whatever is staying on.
something. OK. So OK.
So when we are when we are ranking,
yeah when we are ranking you know the so
there is this event you know this
happened there should be and there is
this expected impact that the we will
still need to sort of you know these.
HCPS we will still need to cluster them
somehow.
So because you can't just say you know
these are the the highest volume ones
Yes.
versus these are not because there are
going to be all kind of other things you
know such as patient population for
example.
You know that this C with a specific,
you know,
Yeah.
medical condition or therapy area,
et cetera,
that you know those things will have to
come into play and then we'll have to
compare them against the their peer group
and then highlight, you know,
Yeah.
anomalies per say.
Yeah. So,
so to put it very to summarize this,
Sorry, yeah.
this particular use case will help to
capitalize on pair wins.
And for this we may need to go right now.
I know we don't have it in a
comprehensive way,
but for this we may have to look at the
prescription behaviors as well.
Well, we have a pair win.
We expected the physicians to prescribe
for a drug. They are not,
which means that the awareness for the
pair win is not yet there.
So what are these physicians prescribing?
So.
So in order to understand this physician
prescription behavior, we will have to.
Read into the EHR clinical notes as well.
So, so, so a lot happening here,
a lot happening here, but but yeah,
Yep.
it's definitely a a use case with a very
good value proposition.
Yeah, I think that configurable.
So how different the so as Jeremy said
OK.
earlier, right,
this will come down to defining pair win
and I think we'll need to understand how
you know similar these different types of
win wins are.
Yeah.
Because if each one and is expected,
in fact you know impact is very different
from from each other,
then it will become quite complex to
build. If it's somewhat similar,
then we may be able to just build some
templates here and say for your heritage
this new type of a win.
Yes.
Like and here is the expected impact and
you know this bunch of different
configurations and it it pretty much just
works, you know,
so so it can start with classifying,
you know,
detecting you know the one of the known
wins and then just follow that path per
se.
I think you know they will. They'll need,
they'll need to have a bunch of detail
Yep.
Absolutely, absolutely, yes.
So while initially we'll have to come
here. You know requirement, Yep.
Yeah.
with the standardized requirements,
once we have reached a stable stage with
the standardized requirements,
we can then further move into the phase
two,
which is the configurations you're
talking about, Hasan.
OK.
So.
Launch Excellence.
We want to understand the early adopters
for the brand,
the mid adopters and the late laggards,
as in we have a brand in the market and
we want to know who are the first,
let's say decile or first top 10
physicians we can reach out to for our
drug.
Which is in the market and then who are
the ones we reach on later on.
So this is like segregating your targeted
physicians by earlier doctors for the
treatment and the late laggards for the
treatment.
And I think Sunil will take this up
further in the prototype that he has.
We do have additional use cases which is
switch opportunity and trigger alerts.
Then we have HCP targeting for patient
identification and access driven label
expansions.
All these are very comprehensive in
themselves.
For 18th of December we are targeting
these first three use cases.
Only so I I I wouldn't want to take the
remaining three.
We can of course talk about it at some
other time.
Shall we look at the prototype for the
first three, Hassan and Jeremy?
And then maybe Sunil can get into the
data entities required for these three
use cases.
Sorry, the three use cases by December,
I don't think it's real estate friendly
Yeah, yeah.
at all. OK,
so that would be my very initial feedback.
I mean there is quite a bit of
requirements work that needs to happen
Mm-hmm.
here that will need to be.
Yeah, we need, you know,
even just connecting all this data
properly and normalizing it, et cetera,
will will take some time.
Yeah.
We will need to find a way to fund this
stuff. None of this is funded right now.
OK.
So I want to have very clear expectations,
right? So they're all doable.
I I you know I I don't see any
substantial issues with you know but you
Yeah, they're all doable for sure, yes.
know everything you know everything from
defining from you know the the the the
the data the impact you know these these
events their configurability you know for
whatever that happens to be you know that
we'll need to define.
Evaluation criteria have time for at
least some level of reasonable testing.
The timelines are not realistic.
Yeah, yeah.
And I think there's an opportunity here
for us to work together better as well,
because this is the first time I'm seeing
the stack and I frankly should have been
involved at the time that this was being
drafted.
Maybe not at the very early stages,
but at the time we started writing things
down, having me in the room is an.
Minister.
Everyone,
because it helps us come up with a
realistic sense of what's the size of
something, how much work is it gonna take,
broadly speaking,
and it's a little bit of a failure mode
to have a product team.
And this isn't a comment about you guys.
This happens a lot of times,
but a product team create a road map,
Yeah.
not talk to data science.
Some dates and then they come to us and
we just say, well,
I mean that the dates don't make any
sense because we weren't in the room when
Yeah.
we had the discussion about like what it
might take to actually do something.
Jeremy, the day I got,
we got to know we were pointed to you and
to Hassan. I think we got this set up.
It was just that in the middle I was
traveling to Delhi because of which I
couldn't.
OK, that's it.
Yeah, yeah.
I had to cancel the day I traveled that
day itself. I said it.
I would have loved to have this meeting
with you and with Hassan.
Yeah, no, look, it's it's OK.
We did have the conversation. Yeah,
we had the conversations with Raghu.
Yeah,
it's it's an opportunity for us to work
But it.
I had multiple conversations with Raghu
with Imran before I finally put the date
better. Yeah, yeah.
Yes.
on the road map.
I would have loved to have this
conversation with you, Hassan and Jeremy.
Nonetheless, it's OK.
Better late than never.
That's where product development happens.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, so so look,
here is what I would recommend, right?
Instead of trying to push through three
use cases and then deliver nothing,
I would suggest picking one, you know,
two. So, so, so give me this,
Hmm, OK, OK.
just just be strategic, right?
So pick the one that's.
That have the highest impact and the low.
So here's what I recommend.
So the next we only have 6 minutes.
So spend a few hours with Jeremy
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
separately.
Dive deep into each of these three use
cases with a goal of getting out of that
meeting or soon after.
So making a determination on the level of
complexity and effort and then the
overall business impact and pick one use
case that has the least effort and the
highest business impact, right.
So that combination per se,
but even if the lowest business impact is
substantial enough,
but the effort is very low.
So pick that one and really focus on
building a very good POC that can be
quickly productionized after in this time
frame. So,
Yeah.
so two months is actually not completely
unreasonable, right?
So for building something 3 use cases in
the current state.
Not realistic, right?
Pick one high impact one and start
Mhm.
defining it and in parallel we'll have to
go and have a conversation with.
I'll probably have to talk to Chris and
Andy, etc. How do we fund this?
How do we resource this, etc.
What can we deprioritize for them?
Because the team is.
Working on a very large number of
initiatives,
Mhm.
all and all the stakeholders that have
asked us to work on those have equal
excitement about them, let's say.
So we'll need to make some decisions on
Yeah.
the prior test.
So that's a parallel effort,
but and as soon as.
First one is underway.
My recommendation will be start defining
the other two in much more detail and
come up with time,
Yep.
Yeah.
you know time for those, right?
Absolutely, Hassan, absolutely,
completely aligned with you.
And the discussions that Sameer and I,
we have had there totally on the similar
lines as you just mentioned. Yeah,
it's not funded for 2025, I agree.
Sameer and I, we're trying to figure out.
How to get whatever we can get resources
bandwidth for 2025? It's funded for 2026,
but for 2025 it's not. You're right, so.
OK.
Yep. Yeah. So we can look. So.
So I think it doesn't mean that a lot of
definition work cannot happen. Also,
you know,
Sure.
OK.
I'll of course I'm I cannot guarantee,
but I'll go and see if there are some
things in this time frame and and and by
the way, meaningful work.
Generally have start after at least some
level of detailed definition, right?
So we're talking at least a few weeks
here, so so spend that time.
Yes.
In the meantime,
I will go and see if there is anything
Oh.
else in the pipeline that will not get
substantially hurt by just delaying it a
little bit and OK,
can I find one person for example?
That can come and start prototyping and
start doing something here. I know,
you know, of course it's not funded,
right? But we, you know,
OK.
we don't get get that, you know,
don't let that become, you know,
a showstopper.
So we'll try to find some bandwidth
somewhere.
That I'll take that action item, right,
that someone that can come and start
helping us. But even that really,
you know,
requires an understanding of the use case.
Which one are we picking?
Because the skill sets may be very
different,
Yes, yes.
like some may require a scientist
building a model, some may require,
let's say, MLE, right, that can, you know,
do.
Yeah.
Quite a bit of work and get it to a
decent state.
So so yeah that the please you know find
a few hours as soon as possible.
I would say you know within the next one
or two days with Jeremy and and.
Yes, absolutely. Absolutely, yes.
Yeah.
No, appreciate.
Appreciate all your suggestions and input,
Hassan. This has been very valuable.
So I think we'll find another 60 minutes
with Jeremy tomorrow to run in because
Sevil has created very comprehensive.
PRD and detailed data specifications as
in he has absolutely pointed from which
data set which field we need.
So I think providing details to that
extent should help us with getting this
out.
In and out in the time frame,
what is possible and yes, Hassan.
We'll try and scope it out and see what
we can deliver by 18 December.
So do we want to do the prototype today
because we've got another two minutes
Perfect.
only?
Or shall we do the demo and the data
discussions in the next 60 minutes that
Sunil puts up on our calendars for
tomorrow?
Well, yeah,
I I don't know how much we can cover in 2
Yeah, yeah. So probably, yeah.
So I I can continue.
minutes, but.
Yeah, we can't go.
I don't know if Jaya and Sunil,
you have another conflict,
but if you don't,
I can continue this discussion for
another 30 minutes or so now and then we
can look at the calendar.
I did.
I have some conflicts tomorrow.
I can't move,
Great.
but we can look at the calendar and try
to find a time.
Tomorrow or the next day to, you know,
block an hour and go through the details.
Yeah.
Cool.
I think we can continue for 30 minutes
then. Sunil, you have 30 minutes,
next 30 minutes, right?
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yes, yes.
OK, yeah.
OK,
I I can stay as well actually my my next
We should. OK, that's great. All right.
That is absolutely fantastic.
Great.
meeting that was just entered.
Thank you so much, Jeremy and Hasan.
Silly, would you want to bring us up? Yes.
Great.
So, so sorry, I want to ask, sorry,
I want to ask one question while we're
still talking about the kind of broader
scope discussion.
Mhm, yeah.
So you I think I heard you say early on
in the discussion that this in this use
case is our you're already solved it.
Using non machine learning methods,
is that right?
Or is this something that you want our
help building? That wasn't clear to me.
This does, yeah, this should.
This is typical descriptive analytics,
Jeremy. So it will not need machine. Yes,
you you heard it right.
OK,
so data science doesn't need to worry
about this use case.
You're right, yes, yes, yeah.
And the another another word about this
OK, great. OK.
module is this is basic and fundamental
to every all the other specialized
modules I've been talking about as in
this provides the preliminary.
Yeah.
That we have in INT.
Understood.
OK, great. So Sunil,
you wanna take the screen?
Sure, absolutely. OK.
And I've stopped to share.
Sure, yeah. OK.
So I can walk you through basically the
prototype first and maybe then discuss
the data required for the all the KPIs
and the metrics whatever I'm showing over
this prototype.
So as Jay mentioned, right,
the first one is the high impact
prescriber and we can take an example of
a product which is Opdivo, right.
And we want to see how the Opdivo is
basically performing in the market first
in the first couple of.
Overview basically.
So it will tell us what is the total
prescription of Opdivo.
Basically from I I have taken the data
from 2023 to 2025 September.
So it will and it this this is basically
our dummy data so.
When we connect the real data,
this number might change.
So this will tell you the total
prescription of that particular product
and what is the total patients on that
particular product,
number of NPIs and the top decile NPIs
and number of.
NP is who are having favorable access.
When I say favorable access,
how many NP is don't have any
restrictions or step therapy associated
with the patient's pair implants.
So that is why the market access data
comes into picture and it will give the
information of.
The favorable access or rested access in
the patient's plans and their
informations.
Sorry, I'm a little confused here.
So I thought the use case was it's a new
drug that's going to be launched, right?
And for that we are going to look for
drugs that are similar in that therapy
area and find prescribers, right?
So.
So basically it can be,
it can be for the existing product. Yeah,
So when?
It can. Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Sorry. Sorry.
sorry to interrupt.
So it can be for existing product and for
the new products. So for existing product,
I just want to see how my drug is
performing in the market, right?
And if I want to launch a drug in the
market, I in the first.
Few months I want to see how my drugs is
performing.
So it is it can be for a existing product
which is there in the market from quite
long time or it will be basically a
product which is just launched and about
to pick in the market or having the
adoption in the market.
The third use case could be you want to
look at the competitor landscape for your
No.
Absolutely, yes.
But, but look,
so this is like a spray and pray type of
product, how your product is performing.
thing, right. So, so, so, so,
so this becomes very reactive instead of
proactive which substantially reduces the
power. So if it's a new product,
Mhm.
so basically you know you don't it
assumes that whatever marketing has you
know happened to.
Prescribers already happened, right?
So the big opportunity is gone already
and now they are seeing how whatever they
have done is impacting the market and
then they will be going back and making
changes, right?
But when you launch a new product,
the very first thing is who do you?
Yeah.
To reach out to before it's launched that
can or at the time of it's launch that
Yeah.
can start prescribing.
So there is actually one thing that we
Mhm.
have already built that can really come
in handy here.
Mhm.
So we have this thing called drug analog
which is built on a knowledge graph.
Right, yes.
And and and what it does is you can take
a drug or characteristics of a drug,
right. So even if it's a brand,
you know and it will give you top K drugs
in that same therapy area that are
similar to it. OK.
So that's a service that's actually about
to go to production.
Yeah.
So you can what you can do here very
easily is you can for this new drug
connect with that API,
pull a list of those similar drugs first,
Thank you. Thank you.
right? So your top five,
top three or whatever similar drugs and
then find high impact prescribers for
those drugs.
Correct. Yeah.
OK.
And once you do that you will basically
have you know and and and and then you
run it on this. So,
so it will say for this right go and
target these you know high prescribers.
So it becomes very you know seamless and
smooth and it adds a lot of value rather
Right.
OK.
than reactive it becomes proactive.
Correct.
Yeah.
So basically it is for the analog studies.
So if you see the brand launch excellence,
that's exactly we have done.
So we will do the analog studies,
right and we will see if a drug is going
to launch in the market,
who will be my early adopters,
lead laggards and the basically the.
Mainstream adapters.
So we have taken all the basically both
the use cases,
but yeah to finalize the what are the
analog drugs we have to take into
consideration that might be helpful
basically to understand what are the top
five drugs we have to consider and see
Yeah.
who are the high impact prescriber,
what is their prescribing pattern so that.
Yep.
Basically,
I can go and target my physician to
prescribe my brand.
Yeah,
and you can look even for existing ones,
Absolutely.
right? You can add another graph here,
another view. So, so,
so there is one that and and this
actually can be done very quickly because
Mhm.
of what you have built and what we have
already built, right.
So just by just by integrating. So,
so basically show how this drug is
performing, right.
That's this graph that you have.
Mhm.
Per SE.
But then there can be another one that
Correct.
says, you know,
here are the top prescribers for similar
Yes.
drugs, right?
And then when you add that and that list
Yeah, OK. Yeah, so.
is different,
then that becomes your target, you know,
and that would add add substantial value,
right?
Yes.
Because because this work is obvious.
Correct.
That one is not right.
That there's a lot of, lot of people,
Yes, yeah, yeah. So basically correct.
So right now we have the anchor therapy.
yeah.
So we can add the comparison therapy to
compare how the computer is basically
working,
who are the top prescriber in that
particular comparison therapy versus my
anchor therapy.
So there is a plan basically in the phase
two where we have to add the comparison.
Yeah.
Therapy to compare my product versus the
computer product,
my prescriber versus the prescriber
compare prescribing the computer brand.
So that's the next phase of POC we are
trying to basically build.
Cool. Yeah.
So this list on the right that you have
that can oh,
so so anchor therapy is the so define
anchor. So anchor is the query per se,
right?
Selected.
Anchor is the one that the user is
interested in. OK, OK, so so so yeah,
Yes, absolutely. Yes, yes.
Yes.
that's also that can simply be the input
to the drug analog, right.
And that can it can give you top K.
Yeah, yeah.
Drug with bunch of information that you
you can ignore the information but you
just take the drugs right meeting certain
thresholds and Jeremy can help you
Yes.
connect with Luca who is leading that
initiative and you can just use the
service right.
It's currently being built for clinical
about to go live in clinical and then you
yeah you you take that and you can just.
OK.
Add a few graphs for it and deep dive
type of information and also make it
Sure, yeah.
OK.
interactive right?
So the drug analog can essentially
Sure.
recommend bunch of things and the user
show all them them to the user.
Maybe everything is selected by default
and you're pulling everything the
Yeah, makes sense.
statistics and combining,
but the user is able to deselect and take
something out right or.
Yeah, that's.
Or or add something else that they want
and it can be average of statistics or
Absolutely.
the statistics by drug,
by a competitor drug,
right or similar drug.
OK. Yep, Yep. OK.
So then I just want to see how my total
prescription works and what are my new
prescription from the from the quarters
basically from 2023 to 2025 and how the
number of prescribers and the growth
looks like from last two years.
And this is basically the product
overview, right? But my main targeting,
my main agenda is basically to see the
prescribing pattern,
who are the prescriber, right?
So here the prescribers part coming to
picture.
So here I will see who are the top ranked
prescribers, what is their specialty,
what is their affiliation details.
Mhm.
And what is the patient count and the RX
volume they have prescribed so far and
what is the growth rate?
So this will basically help me if I want
to target so I can add list to the target.
I can send this send this alert message
to the sales Rep and do maybe added this
to CRM,
Viva CRM and then do the targeting for
the for the.
Physician to the physician basically.
So this is basically a traditional way of
Yep.
doing the commercial targeting,
but the only part we have added is the
market access data because if we
integrate the market access data then we
will come to know let's say we have the
100 physician,
but out of 100 physician only 30%
physician having the favorable access.
That means there is a access barrier for
my particular brand, right?
For that reason we have showing the US
favorable access by state in which state
my drug is performing very well and who
are the prescribers having the favorable
access and what is the percent of the of
the favorable access.
So if you see the state wise if I see in
them.
Number of NPI counts, the RX volumes,
the patient count and the favorable
access percentage.
So it will tell me basically the reasons
or the state where my drug is performing
well and having favorable access and
where is my prescriber are basically
right now.
So that is what we basically try to show
the high impact prescriber in this
particular module.
Any question Hassan or Jeremy?
Yep.
Yep, I have a pretty technical question,
but if you go down to the list of
prescribers,
so so I know this is a prototype,
Yes.
Yeah.
but just thinking about what this might
look like if it was real,
where does this prescriber view live?
So the end the RWD is all at the event
view, right? So there's a claim event.
There's a visit event or something like
that.
Yes.
So something has to do a pretty big group
by and aggregate with some business logic
in there and make that available.
So is is that is there a plan to,
you know,
have that as a data source which feeds
this and then which can then feed data
science services?
Or are you thinking to kind of do all
that on the fly,
which I think might be really difficult?
No, Jeremy,
we're not planning to do this on the fly
OK.
because like I said,
we want to have a robust data strategy.
I'm in conversations with Armahan,
Imran and Raghu on how to architect that
side and.
OK.
When I had this conversation with Imran
today,
he said that for some of the events that
you just talked about, Jeremy,
there the rappers do exist,
but those event rappers currently do pull
for diagnosis treatments.
And for,
but it doesn't pull for pull for NPIs.
So that's an additional wrapper that
Imran will have to work.
I'm not sure even after building that
wrapper,
this serves our purpose because we're
trying to get a dedicated.
Data architect for this suite of products
because we ultimately are going to need
one single integrated data asset.
I don't think that exists right now.
Yeah.
I am having conversations with some more
folks to understand if this.
This integrated data exists.
If it doesn't,
we're going to have to create one journey.
So yeah,
to to answer your question precisely,
we don't have that right now,
but we don't want to do it on the fly
either. I mean,
OK.
we don't want to execute one query,
create 10 joins in the query and then
Yeah, alright.
pull the data.
We don't want to do things like that.
Yep, Yep. Great.
I just want to make sure that we
Yeah.
understand that there's a significant
amount of work there just to make that
data look like this, yeah.
It's oh, it's a whole foundational work.
I think once we have the foundation,
So.
OK, great.
Yep.
we can go on creating as many pop outs
out of that common data model as we want.
Great.
Excellent.
Good.
Sure.
OK, OK. Moving to the next module,
which is basically the market access pull
Yeah.
through, right.
So here I just want to basically what is
the use case Ajay mentioned.
Basically we want to see if there's a
pair win,
but that pair win is not reflecting in
the data right for the product sales data.
Or the prescribing data or maybe the
prior part is already there, right?
And right now the prescriber are not
aware of the product market access
barriers, right? And prescribing it left,
right and center and the claims are
getting rejected, right?
So basically I just want to show.
So right,
how this particular brand is performing
2.
Oh.
right now in the market and what is the
access barrier.
So if you see the rejection due to the
PNST for that particular brand, right,
it's showing 17% is rejected for that
particular brand and the 19% are patients
are basically abandoning that particular
brand.
And then NPI having high restriction
network means the patients,
the NPI who are writing those prescribing,
the prescribing those brand are basically
falling into lot of restriction like PAST
or quantity limitations or getting
rejected by the payers.
So,
so this information will tell me about
how my the product is performing or is
there any access barrier attached to my
product as of now?
And because of that my access barrier,
what is the rejection rate?
What is the abundant rate of my product,
right?
And that that's what I have sold
basically in quarter by quarter.
The rejection rate and abandonment rate,
but the the main agenda is basically to
show at the NPI level, right?
At the NPI level,
who who are the NPI having the high API
burden score, right?
Let's say the patient,
the prescriber is writing 100 claims out
of the 100 claims.
70% claims is having,
let's say a PA burden,
PA are attached to that particular plan
of the patients.
So the burden is basically 70% and
because of the PA patient are basically
abandoned that particular product or
basically the claims are getting
abandoned, right? So it will tell you.
You the PA burden score,
the rejection rate and the abundant rate
and it will also tell me the details of
the formularies, right?
What are the formularies attached to that
particular physician where it is covered,
where it is prior authorized and required
because it is basically a combination of
the claims and market access data.
Right.
And we also get those information from
the clinical nodes to see if basically in
the clinical nodes if patient is
basically rejected or abandoned that
particular product because there is a
mention of a prior authorizations or
because of there is a mention of the high
co-pay impact, right.
So those basically we can get also from
the.
Clinical nodes and we are planning to
integrate both clinical nodes,
claims data and the market access data to
show what is the how what is the NPI
OK.
facing the highest prior authorization
and step therapy a burden in for that
particular product.
Then coming to the next one,
it will tell you the payer, yeah.
Sorry, sorry. Can you go back?
Can you go back a little bit?
Sure, sure.
I have a question here. So,
so from everything that I've heard,
so that all makes perfect sense.
I understand it.
For everything that I've heard, the,
you know, the PA burden quantification,
the rejection rate.
Possibly even the abandonment rate is all
traditional analytics.
The part that you're looking for us to
help you solve is the why.
Does that sound correct?
Yes.
And also we will get some of the
information from the clinical notes,
right, which is validate, right.
If his patient is basically abandoned
because of the prior authorizations or
Yeah, that that's the why, right.
So you can observe through claims,
maybe yes, yes.
The what?
for example,
that a patient is on therapy A and then
they switch to therapy B,
but you don't know why.
Yes.
So the question is,
did the patient switch because of some
Yeah.
authorization burden either from the
perspective of the provider or the
Absolutely. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Yeah.
patient, OK.
I got it. OK.
All the patients switched because of some
adverse events because the safety profile
Yes, correct, correct.
of the drug was not good and across 100
patients,
Yep.
Yeah.
the same safety event is seen across it
is 70 patients. For example, Ozempic,
out of the 100 patients who were injected
with Ozempic, 70 had a cardiac event.
Yep.
I'm I'm just throwing numbers on the fly,
but that that we only can get from
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
clinical units generally.
Yes, the lack of efficacy, adverse effect.
Yes, of course.
Yeah, so.
OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, so so Jeremy,
I think it can reuse quite a bit of
OK.
infrastructure we are building for the
nodes project, right.
Yes, yes.
So the with the with the summary in the
generic data feed.
Yeah.
So we would just want to make sure that
the, you know,
generic data feed have these events that
we are looking for here or the
explanation, right.
Yeah.
And and yeah,
then if it's a patient is not summarized,
it can be done even on the fly or
something along those lines.
Yeah, I mean,
Notes Chat is a good prototype of this,
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
OK.
frankly. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so this seems seems very solvable.
Um, but.
Yeah.
Yep, Yep, Yep.
And Hassan and Jeremy, I'd like to know,
since we're talking about clinical notes,
we must be having a road map of the
therapeutic area,
the diseases of the products that we are
processing the clinical notes for.
I'm asking this so that we create a
parallel and aligned road map for our
Yeah.
product.
As well.
Yeah. So that's a good point.
I mean we it's really driven by no chat
sales, right.
For now we will you know drive summarize
OK.
everything. That's the plan.
But but look we we can use multiple
Phone.
business justifications, right.
So if you have a road map.
You know if if you want say here are
these five or ten,
you know top areas that you want to go
after or something along those lines,
we can go back and summarize those
because now we have a business
justification as long as you know you
have potential revenue associated with it
She.
and stuff like that that justify the
spend, we can go and process those.
OK. So that will take us some time.
So do you already have the list of the
therapeutic areas,
diseases or products that have already
been processed so that when we do the
sales pitches, we'll use those, yeah.
So let me, yeah. So let me,
let me can share, yeah.
Yeah, I'll share that.
When we have a next session,
I'll walk you through what we've done and
show you the UI and talk about the data
Hey.
strategy. Right now,
basically what we have is 26 high-value
Tas and a small sample of each of those.
Yeah.
OK. All right.
We'll take it in the next session.
Tell me that sounds good.
Cool.
Yeah. OK.
The next use case is basically the brand
launch excellence, right, as we discuss,
right. So we just want to know,
let's say first six month of our launch,
right,
who are my early adopters who are
basically first time?
So, so, so sorry,
that's one thing which is related to the
previous one. Yeah,
maybe complementary for the feature,
not right now,
but there is this PA pilot that we have
just worked on, right.
So if we are able to, you know,
OK.
if someone is going,
so I'm not sure who the exact audience of
this is, right, but if it's.
Anything to do with providers or you know
so so so when prior authorization fails
right there is a we are building a
recommendation system on how to get prior
authorization.
So so this same salesperson can you know
OK.
Mhm.
with IPA failure rates right.
So same salesperson can go and sell that.
Product once that's in the works.
So just just a comment,
OK, Yep, that makes sense. Yeah,
makes sense.
I mean it won't impact what you're doing
yet, but anyway.
Sure. Yeah.
Sorry, yeah, go to the next one. Yep.
Yeah, sure.
So the next one is basically the brand
Yes.
loans excellence, right?
We just want to know how my product is
basically performing within the six
months of a launch, right?
Who are my early adopters,
align adopters basically having favorable
access and what is the first average time
for?
From the first approved to the first
skipped right?
And what is the time for the adoptions
right?
Time to pick adoptions where after that
it become plateau right?
So this will give you the significant
overview of my product launch once it is
launched then how might.
Growth is basically happening from the
time of launch to till date and then I
just segment those physician based on the
segmentations,
basically their adoption rate, right.
So we can basically see early adopter.
Yeah.
Mainstream adopter,
laggard and later adopters basically.
Then we want to see who what is the time
to 1st prescriptions from the 30 days of
launch,
how many prescribers are basically
prescribing that particular brand from 30
to 60 days of launch,
how many prescriber are basically
prescribing brand.
So it will basically tell me the adoption.
Rate from my launch till date or maybe I
can have a time period I can define that
right and then coming to the favorable
access where I just want to know the NPI
having though who are prescribing those
brands or the brand basically how many
are having favorable access.
Having excellent favorable excellent
access or having good or limited they're
prescribing it but it is getting rejected
or PA or SD right.
So we have to understand the prescribers
are basically prescribing the brand right.
But if there any market access barrier
attached to those brands or for the
payers for the patient plan.
So this will give you all the details
about the product performance,
then coming to the NPI by prescription
volumes.
So here it will tell me what are The Who
are the NPIs, their specialty,
the reasons,
what are the channels they are basically
having to the the pair mix right and the
volume and the.
Uh tag basically if they are key opinion
leaders or they have the high potentials
uh to uh prescribe my brand or they have
already established uh physicians right?
So it will basically generate a target
list right?
Then uh I can uh basically send a alert
to the Uh.
Sales Rep or the brand team so that they
will do the when they'll do the call
planning and call activity,
they should target those physician who
are basically having high potential
physicians.
OK, Yep. So, so.
So, so we yeah, Hassan and Jeremy,
we plan to this.
All of this data will eventually feed
into form Viva track so that the list of
the targeted HCP's can be given to the
sales Rep and they can go and reach out
to the HCP's.
Yep.
Yeah.
So, so this, this, this,
this would be very broad, right?
Yeah.
So maybe add some filters here because
whoever is doing it,
Mm-hmm. OK, yeah.
we're generally going to look for,
you know,
That reason, yes.
who should I target or who are the top in
New York City or New York or whatever.
Yes, yes, yes.
So maybe somewhat of a flexible way of of
filtering it down.
The default view can be exactly this,
but then you filter by.
State by city, zip code, you know,
whatever they want to. OK, so that's one,
Correct, correct, correct, correct.
right? So that's that's one feedback.
The second feedback is that there were
there can be and maybe that's a separate
use case, right?
But what we were discussing at that time
was that.
Let's say you have a limited sales
resources that are going to target
Mhm.
certain physicians to hit, you know,
certain goals in a certain time period.
Let's say for Q3, I want to increase,
you know,
the market penetration of this drug by
this much in this area,
but but that's always, you know, by area,
right?
So who are the top 2030 fifty 100 you
know whatever doctors that I should
Yep.
target and and then what evidence can I
arm you know these sales reps with right
Mhm.
whoever is going to target need to have
you know have to have some information
OK.
Mhm.
like so and and the idea at that time was
that we can provide for example their.
Peer set with that are prescribing higher
than them,
so have very similar patient
characteristics,
but the peer set is writing that drug to
40% of their patients,
whereas this specific prescriber that
they're going to is writing to 20% and
then you can also have.
More supporting data from RWD which
basically says here is the so so because
they're prescribing this here, here,
here is the positive impact on the
patient population right.
So so stuff like that can be you know
Absolutely, absolutely, yes.
Yeah, sure.
very good,
you know make make this substantially
Yep, yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
Also we are we can customize.
more valuable.
Basically we can give a zip to zip to
territory of configure file here because
all pharma company having their different
zip and territory mapping, right?
So if I basically upload my zip and
territory alignment here,
I can get the list of.
Physicians in my territory or maybe a
territory assigned to my to me, right?
So basically we can have a configurable
file here basically to upload the GPT
territory mapping and they can be
targeted based on the reasons or maybe
the sales Rep who want to basically.
Assign with that particular physician.
Sounds good. Yep. OK.
So Sunil,
can we add both of these suggestions from
Yep.
Hassan onto the prototype? Yeah,
both the filters that Hassan mentioned
Yes, yes, absolutely. Yeah. Yeah, I can.
I can do that. Yes. Yeah.
and the additional data that we want to
provide to the sales Rep fully equip them
to go and target the doctors.
Yeah.
The.
Yes, for sure.
Yeah.
And that can that can also change the
ranking per se, right.
Because here what so, so,
Yes, yes, yes.
so the difference is you know whether we
are just presenting the current facts or
we are predicting something that can
change facts for the future, right. So,
Mm.
so that the letter becomes much more
useful because the the, the current stuff,
Yeah.
I mean you know we are of course.
We have a bunch of different data sources
that are coming together.
It's still useful for someone to see,
but but again, it goes back to, well,
here are the ones that are already doing
something that they want versus the ones
that that we have a bigger opportunity to
make a difference.
Yeah.
Right, right. OK. Yeah, we can basically,
if you want to think through,
maybe we can add AIML to see what is
their prescribing pattern,
who are having the high potentials and
add some of these peer comparisons, right,
1.
to see.
What is their rank should look like,
right?
So basically we can add AIML stuff and do
the fission segmentation and provide the
list basically.
Yeah.
We discussed it, Sunil, right?
This we want to do it in phase two.
Yeah, yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
we did. Yeah, yeah.
You didn't mention we talked about it.
Yeah.
Mm.
So basically this is 3 use cases.
We will try to basically complete by this
year. But yeah,
as per basically we'll see how we can
take it forward. But yeah,
the rest of this basically.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Look,
some some of these could be, yeah,
We are tagging for next year, yeah.
some of these could be mediate,
some of these could be phase two, right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I'm thinking in terms of, you know,
what can add a lot more value, right.
Yeah, absolutely. Yes.
Yeah. All right. So why don't you,
Jaya and Sunil,
So cool. All right. Yeah.
thank you for sharing this with us.
It was extremely helpful and interesting.
Why don't you share that deck, please?
And also that PRD that Sunil has worked
Yeah, I.
on so I can have a chance to review those
and then let's take a look at the
calendar.
If you wanna drop us on,
I think that's fine,
Yes.
but let's take a look at the calendar and
pick a time tomorrow that.
Yeah, I'll I'll drop. I need to go.
Thank you. Bye.
Yeah. Thank you, Miss. Yeah. Jeremy,
I think Saleel will schedule another 30
Yeah, cool. All right. Thanks.
minutes between us tomorrow and we should
be able to go through the data
specifications.
That's fine,
but the only times that I can do it.
So you're in India, right?
So I understand there's a large time gap
between 7:00 and 8:30 Pacific.
I have a window where I can move things
OK.
around, but after 8:30 I can't.
OK,
so drop us the slot that you're available.
We we we'll accommodate accordingly and
then we'll set it up according to you how
Yep. OK, great.
it works between all of us.
Yeah, yeah.
So.
Great. Sounds good.
So.
OK. Thank you, Jeremy.
It's been really nice meeting you.
Yeah, nice meeting you.
Thank you for sharing. All right.
Thanks, Dharmin. Thanks there. Yeah. Bye,
bye.
Thank you. Thank you, Sunil. Bye, bye.
Take care. Bye.
Thanks there. Bye, bye.